[Music]  and no one notices that's the crazy  thing right  yeah  that's the crazy thing is is because  you're living this  kind of groundhog day sort of on stage  that any tiny thing  seems huge but yeah you know the  audience has seen it for the first time  they don't know that you're not supposed  to  put that up yeah  i remember you saying i think it was  during macbeth i think you you had said  that at one point you you  you knew where you were supposed to get  to in a speech but you couldn't remember  how to start it so you just came up with  a piece of made-up shakespearean lines  and then jumped onto the next bit  i did making up shakespeare's never a  good idea  and and the actor who was playing my son  it was justin stitches  as how as i was making up shakespeare oh  [Music]  all through the night you're shining  bright i'm your host the baby you're my  pearl